astronomers for the first time have
detected the faint hum of gravitational
waves echoing throughout the Universe
teams of scientists across the world
have been monitoring space to observe
the phenomenon which Albert Einstein
predicted more than a century ago they
don't exactly know what's causing the
hum but it may be coming from
supermassive black holes spiraling
together before merging
let's get more on this we can speak to
Michael Lamb a research scientist at The
seti Institute he was part of the team
that conducted the nanograph study he
joins us from Washington DC thank you
for joining the program so if I
understand this correctly scientists had
suspected that these gravitational waves
existed but now they have proof of this
uh we actually have had proof of them
before the ligo and Virgo collaborations
in 2016 they ended up detecting
gravitational waves but in a different
part of the spectrum so what I mean by
that is if you look with your eyes you
see light of a certain wavelength range
so you can see red to blue but there's
other light that exists out there
there's infrared which is longer
wavelength than red there's ultraviolet
which is a shorter wavelength than blue
there's x-rays there's radio waves and
so all of these different kinds of waves
are electromagnetic waves
in 2016 ligo and Virgo announced the
discovery of gravitational waves for the
first time which is a completely
different way of observing the universe
they observe very high frequency
gravitational waves that is waves with
very very very short wavelengths and so
what we have done for the first time is
open up a second window on the
gravitational wave Universe okay looking
at very very very long period waves
right and and you think that these waves
are caused by massive black holes
spiraling together what will that tell
us more about black holes themselves
it will tell us it can tell us a little
bit about black holes
um one of the more important things I
think is that it will tell us a lot
about the environments around these
massive black holes we know that these
massive black holes exists at the center
of every Galaxy our galaxy has a massive
black hole in the center and we know
that galaxies merge together
when we look out in in space and so as
the two galaxies merge we expect that
the black hole should merge
um and we now have or we think we have
some evidence for this that is one of
the possible mechanisms of the
gravitational waves so how do you take
this forward how does this how do you go
forward with this research
yeah great question
um we have every time astronomers have
opened a new window into studying the
universe we have found really new and
exciting things
for us as we observe more of these
objects called pulsars which make up our
detector as we observe them for longer
we're able to gain better sensitivity
and that will help us answer a lot of
fundamental questions about the universe
how Galaxies have merged and evolved
over the entire course of the Universe
um possibly finding interesting signals
out there from the very very very
beginning of the universe around the Big
Bang
lots of other possible things and so
this is only really the beginning and we
really think that we're opening up this
window to new and exciting discoveries
it's interesting you say this is the
beginning because
Albert Einstein in 1916 was the first to
kind of think about gravitational waves
or the idea of gravitational waves as a
scientist researcher do you find it
incredible that so far back he was able
to predict their existence
I do I think Albert Einstein is
incredible in many ways uh he has come
up with an incr uh an entire framework
of how we understand gravity in the
universe and so far nothing has been
able to
break that understanding uh of gravity
uh I think what's even more incredible
is that it's taken a hundred years for
us to reach the point where we were
first able to detect very high frequency
gravitational waves with ligo and Virgo
and then a few years later uh we have
evidence for low frequency gravitational
waves
um from collaborations such as my own
and other International Partners around
the world it just goes to show that even
though these were predicted by Einstein
it's been an incredibly hard effort in
order to do so and it's taken the work
of lots of people over many decades well
thank you for your amazing work Michael
Lamb research scientist at the city
Institute thank you
thank you